okay we're back
we have no idea what the [ __ ] this is we
got a great connection
it's just something we don't know what
it is software problem
i don't know what it is it could be a
million things and i feel like i've
checked everything that i know to check
and
i don't know it's just it's really
annoying yeah
that's got to be a record on shut down
time right usually it's like we get it
to like the two hour
mark and then it'll start to do it but
it's like we didn't yeah we got
31 minutes and it just [ __ ] crashed
yeah
and like i said i haven't used this
computer today i restarted a bunch of
times i updated everything i did
everything i was supposed to do
and you know still does it [ __ ] happens
[ __ ] happens
uh oh frugal videographer that's
actually a good idea
check see what time your virus scanner
kicks in that will slow you down okay
i'll have to look into that it might be
that i think it does it at 4am but i'm
not
entirely sure of that i mean
it could be because i have it on some of
the other computers and maybe i'm
thinking of that what the hell's
happening up there
is that is that a truck that sounds like
a truck or a goddamn airplane
i think it's a truck it's a truck or
somebody's
really really loud stereo
even pokey ran to see what was going on
i told him i was i i kept having a
nightmare and this
like woke me up this morning i had like
a nightmare about not really a nightmare
but
i had a really weird dream about pookie
where i had to leave her with some
relatives
to go do something with some other
relatives
and then i got it wasn't even here it's
like out in this back road
well yeah it's probably on i don't know
what it is markham road or whatever that
road is right there that's probably on
there
uh but yeah so i dreamed that i had to
leave pookie with the
with a relative and like i had to go do
some other [ __ ] with some other
relatives and then i was like this
one relative that i left her with was
kind of like hey i have to go do this
other [ __ ] and
like left it with southern then i was
kind of like well [ __ ] you know
i can't leave her with the i got to get
back home and like take care of pookie
and then i told him too that i was like
i had this dream one time that
we were out in the woods walking with
pookie and then all of a sudden there
were two pookies
and he said you probably dreamed that
because of mirror pookie
yeah how she jumps up and talks to her
reflection in the mirror and we say oh
that's evil mary universe spooky on the
other side of there
maybe that's why she does that pretty
much every night now like i said i
really wish i could get some [ __ ]
video of it okay most of the people are
back yay
looks like t hasn't made it back yet but
um
yeah um we were talking about the omen
yeah yeah it was um
they were better than i remembered them
especially the third one they were
that's what
that's what i'm taking away from it um
the second one was still pretty good it
was the weakest out of the two but it
was still good
it's still good i'm gonna put it
i'm gonna put them all every single one
of them i kind of thought
was on par with the exorcist
even though the exorcist is classic i
thought i think they're as good as the
exorcist
yeah and it's weird because the trilogy
has an almost
exorcist like thing where like the first
one's brilliant yeah the second one
is okay yeah i mean well i'll i will say
omen two is way way better than exorcism
yeah
yeah a lot better nexus two yeah and
then third one pretty [ __ ] good
yeah maybe not quite as good as this
first one but still pretty [ __ ] good
and i mean sam neil was really really
good
as like growing up damien i could have
taken the third one to a new level
though
yeah and that was an expensive movie
it looked expensive it definitely did
look expensive yeah
i think if they'd spent a little bit
more and like i said
got a got a devil scene in there had
gotten that scene
they didn't really when he was in bed
with his girlfriend he started to get
[ __ ] sadistic and [ __ ] and they
really didn't quite
get into the details of what had
happened i think i had gotten a little
bit more in the details of what he did
to her
she was all bitten up the next morning
yeah use your imagination
and she found him in the damn temple of
satan too
the fortress of thief yeah she walked up
to him and i thought she was gonna kick
him in the [ __ ] face man and she
didn't
she could have he was laying right there
yeah well that's that's what he said too
because he's trying to
you know because he's all naked and
sleeping up in the attic or wherever
and uh he's like wouldn't it be funny if
she just started kicking the [ __ ] out
yeah it would have been more realistic i
was like yeah that's what i would have
done
she did something to something bad to
her i mean
you know unless she's like one of those
people that's into it
it's like a whole fifty shades of grey
thing well that was that's what was
happening and i don't think she was into
it
well yeah exactly but she just kept
saying it's like yeah you know you
you want to see who i really am yeah i'm
this
[ __ ] that beats the crap out of you
what could she do though he was like a
billionaire and a
and a [ __ ] ambassador to england and
the devil's side and the devil's son
with magic powers yeah if you
crossed him he killed you oh no kind of
hard to fight against he didn't kill you
the minions of satan killed you
and made it look like an accident made
it all made yeah he couldn't get in
trouble
zach just asked uh what is the weirdest
non-nightmare you've ever had
the weirdest thing man go ahead and
rethink that sentence and ask it again
no the weird the a dream you've had
that's really weird but that's not a
nightmare
stuff that means yeah okay that's i
thought that was pretty clear
me biting the head off of yosemite sam
and it oh that's right i remember you
telling that one and it being a cherry
pop tart yeah what's your guitar from
[ __ ] it's made him a cherry pop tart
sure
that is pretty weird yeah that was good
though most of the dreams that i've had
that are really weird were kind of
nightmares and
i think all the weird ones i turned them
into stories yeah because i remember
having
i think i've told that before like about
that one dream that i had where i was
like in a frat house or it wasn't a frat
house or like an apartment building or
something
and i was like down in the it was dark
and i was down in the um
lobby and there was a kitchen and i was
in the kitchen like making tea or some
washing dishes or some [ __ ] like that
and there was like a girl that was in
there and it was dark for whatever
reason but there was like all these
sirens
like you could see the red and blue like
flickering through the windows
and then like there was a party across
the street which i think was was a frat
house i used to live across from a frat
house was probably why i was thinking
that
and um so then like this dude comes in
with his girlfriend and they start
making out on the floor
and then he pulls her legs up like that
and pulls her feet
off and it was like not it wasn't bloody
or anything it was just like he went
like that and i remember in the dream i
thought to myself because i'm standing
there in the kitchen watching them
because i thought that they didn't see
me and i was like frozen to the spot
and then i was like oh my god he's gonna
pull her feet off and then katoik
they just came off and then he dropped
him on the floor and i remember the
sound that it made
and then it was just like it was just
really real really weird and then the
guy like turned on me and i was like oh
[ __ ] he sees me
and then i tried to stab him because i
was washing dishes and i had a butter
knife in my hand but obviously that
wasn't super effective
when i was a little kid out in
california
i lived on 2524 jackson street and
jackson street
i could look up it in in carson
carson california i could look up the
street the very end of the road i could
see my elementary school
it was called dominguez elementary all
right
and i used to go out and play in the
street and i'd look
look way up the road and see my school
you know
it seemed like it was a million miles
away it was only like three or four
blocks away but i could see it
i had a dream i was looking at the
school
and i saw something moving in the
distance the very end
and it was coming towards me it was a
ball
a big ball you know this big old it was
like a
about the size of a beach ball and they
were purplish we used to throw them at
each other
this is kind of like the prisoner like
that [ __ ] that weird tv show
what was the name of that damn ball that
we used to have
i don't know it's like a big it's like a
purple ball like a dodge ball
used to throw it at each other it
wouldn't it couldn't hurt you it would
just bounce off you right
i saw this thing bouncing towards me and
as it got closer and closer it's just
kind of frozen in fear
and on it was a gigantic [ __ ] face an
angry face with a mouth and eyes and
[ __ ]
yikes yeah and that pretty [ __ ]
scared me
it was weird because like years later a
video game came out stand up video game
called
berserker and you'd be fighting these
robots and this bouncing ball with a
face on it was probably when i first saw
that [ __ ] i was just like
damn that's what i i had a nightmare
that long time
years later yeah i remember having a
dream too when i was
younger that i was on a ride it was kind
of like one of those rides like the old
ones at disney world like the snow white
ones or whatever
um but it was more like the peter pan
one which i haven't been on a long time
and i dreamed that i don't know i don't
remember if i was on foot or in a car
but i go in this one room and it was
like black on the floor and it was all
black walls and black ceiling
and then on the floor were alligators
but they were
made of legos kind of or you know they
kind of look like legos but you can only
see like
their top jaw and their eyes and they
were like all over the floor
and i was like i was really scared
because i thought they'd eat me
so then i for some reason in my pocket
had this little patch of
some it looked like one of those big
band-aids except then it had like fur
all over it
and for some reason i could put this
down on the floor and stand on it even
though it was smaller than my feet
and i could fly so it was like a magic
carpet but it looked like a furry
big band-aid sheila and correctly
[Laughter]
she landed and uh identified that ball i
was talking about as a playground ball
as well yeah this on the playground yeah
and you can bounce it could bounce a
hell out of them they bounce real
real high yeah they made a lot of noise
boing boing when they hit
it's pretty cool i remember those balls
i remember those balls
yeah i got attacked by one of those that
big old face on it
it's weird yeah yeah uh zach asked me if
i'd seen possession i still you know
what i saw it but it was a really long
time ago
and i've actually been wanting to watch
it again because
i was so young when i saw it i was just
like a teenager and that was like ages
ago
so one of these days i'll see it again
because i wanted to do a
retrospective on it as well because that
also has samuel in it
and isabella johnny who was in the
nosferatu remake
and in the tenant now that i'm thinking
about it which is another movie that
hulu just added
didn't they the tenant pretty sure yeah
but yeah so i don't know if obviously
nothing's going to be as good as the
first one i've seen the first one a
zillion times the first one
david warner getting beheaded used to
scare the [ __ ] out of me when i was a
little kid well it's anything that had
beheading in it
scared the [ __ ] out of me when i was a
little kid i don't know why i just i had
a thing about
but i was scared of it but i was also
like fascinated by it i remember when i
was little
and i read about uh [ __ ] was it mary
queen of scots
and she got beheaded and uh they didn't
do it right the first time
like they put her head on the block like
she comes out in the red dress or
whatever
and they put her head on the block and
then the executioner has the axe because
they didn't use a guillotine
and he kind of went like that and he
missed and it didn't kill her like it
still hit her
but it didn't cut her head off and so
she was like still alive and then he had
to kind of keep hacking
and then when he picked the head up like
i think her wig came off
and then like her head just went like
bouncing and i was just like that
[ __ ] horrified me when i read about
that
horrified me because i'm just sitting
there going
because i've always been fascinated with
if you get your head cut off how long
are you aware that you don't that you're
not attached to your body anymore
oh there was a big argument that's i
know and i was like i read about that
too it's like [ __ ] hell
during the french revolution they were
grabbing those heads and looking at them
and see if they were awake going
very still in there yeah very rarely
very rarely somebody to open their eyes
if you slap them they'd open their eyes
and look at you for a second then they'd
fade out
i i don't think the i don't i think
you'd lose consciousness
instantly um because of um
blood pressure problems all the pressure
runs out of your head
yeah i mean if you were aware it would
be like a fraction of a second
it's just like if you ever get thrown
off a motorcycle or [ __ ] thrown by a
horse or [ __ ] punched
you don't actually feel it you know
that's your
body you just yeah you kind of shake it
do it
yeah you kind of shake out you shake it
out and you're like coming up off the
ground like what happened
i think it's what it's like but you
don't ever come back saying what
happened
it's just you're just go off into
oblivion then you're in the spirit world
looking down on yourself going home
going oh [ __ ] there's my head and
there's my body
which one is it me is it my head or my
body what right does my head have to
call itself
there we go talk about the tenant again
that was right that was a nice segue
yeah right yeah yeah it well that's the
thing it's and i think that that's why
the first time i saw the omen i was
probably when did that come out 1976
right
yeah and uh so i must have seen it when
i was
christ seven or eight i want to say
the first time and it creeped me out
like the whole [ __ ] with
the nanny hanging herself that creeped
me out and um
but definitely and mrs baylock was
pretty creepy
but also but the [ __ ] decapitation
oh my god that stressed me out so much
every time that that scene came on like
i always kind of wanted to watch it but
i was just kind of like
oh my god here it comes if you guys
haven't seen the tenant
it's on now you can see it for free
where was that on
i think they just added it on hulu it
might be some other places too i thought
it was on tubey for a while but i don't
know if it's on there anymore
gee if you haven't seen the tenant
you've got to see that one that's the
roman police roman
that's a weird movie i just yeah i
really really like that one
used a lot of samples from that movie on
in skinny puppy songs
yeah i noticed too that when we were
watching
omen 3 last night the shitty commercial
that the guy is showing to damien in
their little theater
um they sampled that for
1000 homo djs which is you know al
jorgensen for ministry
their super group uh what their cover of
super not
like certain mixes of supernaut like at
the beginning
they sampled almost all of that
commercial like before the song starts
and i had forgotten that that's where it
came from so
when we were like watching it i was just
kind of like oh my god i can't even
totally forgot it that's where it came
from because when we watched all the
movies obviously the first one i've seen
like a zillion times
the second one i thought i had seen it
because i remember the kid and i
remember the military school aspect
but when we watched it i'm sitting there
going maybe i never saw this or maybe
i never saw the whole thing all the way
through because i said i definitely
would have remembered a woman getting
attacked by a raven and then run over
several times by a
semi and i definitely would have
remembered that dude getting cut in half
by an elevator cable and i didn't
remember it yet dude getting smashed by
the train
oh yeah that too and the guys being
buried in the underground thing
looking at the damn horror battle on
statue that was a good one too i
remember that when i was kid they're
sitting there praying and the damn
[ __ ]
all the dirt coming in through the damn
ceiling
see that that whole scene you know that
problem because the whole reason they
went down there was because that one guy
was talking to bogan hague in a boogie
and he's like you gotta come down here
and see this [ __ ] [ __ ]
or he told him about it and the guy's
like [ __ ] you i don't believe you and
he's like no i'll show you so he was
like oh you believe me now now we're
both dead good job
but um you know what i mean so i feel
like that guy was like really makes like
a view to just believe me we wouldn't
have we'd just be up there having a
cappuccino right now and we'd be
down here like buried under the [ __ ]
earth and they didn't find him until
later
because i think that the scene at the
beginning of part two right
that only happens a few days after uh
after um what's his face like uh gregory
peck
gets killed right
we do we do that now because on welcome
to the basement yep
they did the omen one year for like one
of their halloween shows
and they were like gregory
the whole time and that's kind of what
they were just
that is kind of what he sounds like yeah
so
now every time i see him now every time
we see him it's like
[Laughter]
a poor [ __ ] dude tv member remember
in tenet where he'd
go in there and [ __ ] go in there and
go to the walked in that one part of the
room and he could see
he could see people in the room staring
at him in the other damn apartment
and eventually he goes over there and
it's a [ __ ] room that has all those
hieroglyphics written on the inside of
it doesn't he find a tooth in the wall
there oh that freaked me out so bad and
it turned out it was his tooth wasn't it
no it was uh simone tooth yeah that's
right
that was weird that was such a weird
movie he throws himself out the window
he's all busted up
[ __ ] he wakes up in the hospital and
they go stella is that you ah
oh god it's a [ __ ] time loop
that's terrifying well she see to me
if you're gonna scare me with a movie i
feel like
[ __ ] i don't know i have really weird
idiosyncratic stuff that freaks me out
the scenes in the tenant like you said
when he looks
okay people seeing looking somewhere and
seeing themselves
that freaks me out yeah if it's done we
saw he looked back he saw himself
looking at him
looking at him through the window
because if that happened to me i would
absolutely
[ __ ] my pants because think how [ __ ]
freaky that would because david lynch
does that kind of [ __ ] all the time
and that like well i mean that's kind of
like
ingmar bergman i think did that kind of
[ __ ] which speaking of which
i think this didn't get on my uh top
horror movie
uh list did it hour of the wolf did i
mention that
i might have that ingmar bergman movie
watch that you'll see where like david
lynch got some ideas from he didn't rip
it off but
it's very um lynchian in
its uh in its imagery
um because some surrealist imagery i
think is scarier than
just seeing something that's like oh
it's a ghost or oh it's like a
you know monster coming at you it's like
you know that's scary but
um well in the um and what made the tent
so good is that he was slowly losing his
[ __ ] mind
yeah and but then you're not sure is he
really losing his mind
or are they making him lose his mind are
they
trying to convince him that he's stella
yeah because that because that's another
thing like
maybe stella it was what was her name
simone simone
stellar was israel johnny that was the
one that came to visit yeah yeah
yeah they tried to convince him that he
was simone
or was simone possessing him or is he
just losing his [ __ ] mind you don't
know
yes and you never know right it's
ambiguous like i said ambiguity works
depending i mean you can't go too
ambiguous where i'm just watching it go
what the [ __ ] is this i don't even know
what i'm watching
you do have to have thank you zach um
you do have to have some kind of
grounding in
you know reality and you have to have a
grounding in people's actual
fears you know what you're doing yeah if
you know what you're doing
you can really i mean that's why like i
said i find david lynch's movies way
more unsettling
than a lot of horror movies just because
then he's not even trying to make horror
movies he's just trying i mean the whole
[ __ ] winky's diner scene from
mulholland drive is scary as [ __ ] and
that's like not even
i don't even know why it's scary nobody
knows why it's scary it just is
i don't know if it's just like this
weird he has this weird way of shooting
it where it's like the camera looks like
it's kind of floating
like it's this really weird like kind of
thing and then it's like this really
really good like build up of tension
build up
this is like kind of a jump scare at the
end but not like a regular
jump scare and like i said a lot of the
[ __ ] in his movies that
freak me out is like you know robert
blake being like i'm at your house right
now like all that kind of [ __ ] like
[ __ ] freaks me out i don't know why
um but yeah so that that's why that part
of the tenant freaks
i mean him finding the tooth in the wall
that's another thing that freaks me out
is like
you just kind of like [ __ ] around
your own apartment or whatever
and then suddenly you find oh look a
tiny little door that you didn't know
was there then you go and then there's
like something like inexplicable
that could have that seems like it has a
sinister
uh meaning but you don't exactly know
what that sinister meaning is that's way
scarier to me
than like finding oh it's a bl it's a
skull
you know you're gonna read zack super
chat it says also worth noting
is the tenant was shot by bergman's
regular cinematographer sven nyqvist
well there you go well that probably
would explain it
but yeah i mean don't you think [ __ ]
like that like finding just a tooth
to me is way scarier than finding like a
whole skull there was a bunch of weird
[ __ ] in that movie we had to be patient
for it to all
kind of come out
you know what i mean that's not we
recommended that movie
uh years back and some people got back
by wasting my time with that movie yeah
some people just don't get it you know
they don't have a taste for it
you know it's not some of these some of
these
movies of course you know they came from
a pre internet age and
some of these kids you know they can't
watch them they can't actually watch
them and
i'm not saying bad about you know
[ __ ]
zenith is like that you know which we
talk all the time he can't watch
anything for longer than about 15 or 20
minutes then he's got to stop
and then he'll take a break and then
he'll come back and watch another 15 or
20 minutes of it they just don't have
the the attention span
i guess it's just we grew up watching
three hour movies not you know no
problem
two hour movie well and sometimes you'd
have you'd rent like two or three movies
and i'd you just sit there all night and
watch
me you get a [ __ ] pizza with your
friends and you just be sitting like
watching three or four slasher movies in
a row
that's why a lot of movies i don't have
a problem with that at all i think
that's why
movies and theater arcana and endangered
art form because uh
we grew up with the experience of going
to the movies and sitting down and
watching something on a big screen and a
crowd of people
and can sit there for two and a half
hours
concentrated on a single story and you
know the modern era isn't like that they
pause they get up they go away little
bitty screen in their hand
they just they just came up that way
they don't
they don't have a nostalgia for that
time they didn't grow up in that
well i'm always kind of like i mean and
not everybody everybody can enjoy things
however they want to it's like i said
i'm not judging anybody's [ __ ] it's like
if you want to watch a movie and then
look at your phone at the same time it's
like look it's no skin off my ass i
don't really give a [ __ ]
um but when i watch a movie i want to
watch
the movie yeah i don't want to be like
glancing over here and be like hey
what's going on on [ __ ]
instagram hey let's do it you know i
don't really want to be like that i want
to kind of like get
involved in the story or i'm not going
to bother watching it i had that dude
sitting next to me
in that [ __ ] we were watching it was
uh was one of those
mcu movies and he had his little phone
and um we were in that
in that dolby theater remember yeah it
was in the next one the nice chairs
he checked that he started checking that
[ __ ] every five minutes i just [ __ ]
took that phone from him
he looked at me like i was [ __ ] crazy
give me that [ __ ] hey he was scared
though
just looked at him and i said it's
[ __ ] pissing me off i'll [ __ ]
break this phone
and he goes let me get my phone back and
i say i give it to back to you at the
end of the show
they should probably just take
everyone's cell phones i mean i know you
might need it for emergencies or
something like that i get it but
i was old enough to be his dad so the
thing about it though is that
i'm not even saying that it's a
generational thing because a lot of
times when we've gone to movies
about half the time when it's some
[ __ ] on their phone or their phone is
ringing or somebody talking
it's old people yeah because they don't
know how to turn it down phone off
it was just that one it was just that
one kid
it's just that one kid you know i said
[ __ ] you know i said
i'm gonna get mad you know okay okay
i'm gonna get mad because he realized he
couldn't control me they'd have to call
the cops
well i don't think people understand
because they're so used maybe they're so
used to staring at their phones they
don't realize in a dark room
that's right very very distracting they
don't give a [ __ ] it's very strong
[ __ ] like you're sitting right next to
me bro it's like [ __ ] it's right
there in my [ __ ] face
stop it if i get mad i get mad with some
of these people you know
i let them know that they're not gonna
be able to reason with me
i don't i don't accept reason it gets to
a certain point where it's not reason
isn't gonna be
jenny knows you can't reason with me
you know if you're reasoning with me
then that means you're gonna do
something bad to me
or trying to get over on me you know
don't use reason with me
just yeah i've tried it doesn't work
well you can do it a little bit all
right
i always see whenever somebody
approaches me like they're gonna try to
reason with me is they're trying to
convince me
to give up something i have for their
benefit
it doesn't have anything to do with my
benefit let's do it their benefit so i
see it as begging you know
because i can reason anybody into doing
anything if i [ __ ] have it all
planned out
how do you think those girls ended up
sucking dick and then porn movies
somebody reasoned them into that [ __ ]
they talked him into
i don't know if that's used to be what
it was this used to be i think
uh all that all they wanted was some
[ __ ] money that's part of it yeah
yeah yeah well that wasn't somebody
else's reason that they they were
reasoning
well maybe i can make a bunch of money
quick doing this and it sucks but you
know there's usually a dude standing
there or a girl standing there i want
you to meet this guy we
we're going to get that money that you
need real quick this this and then yeah
that's how it was back in the old school
days you see that but the thing is i
don't think you can do it too much
anymore
but you know i heard whole stories about
what was going on in the 70s and the 80s
you know i mean it was before porn was
mainstream
they were all talked into it yeah i
think that was i don't think that's the
problem anymore because everybody knows
what they're getting into
um i feel like porn is so ubiquitous
nowadays that it's like you know you
can't you have to
know what it is you have to be really
naive you do not know what that is
to not know what it's gonna entail yeah
right nowadays i'm just saying
no i was laughing because brittany was
talking about that progressive
commercial and that's exactly what i
thought of
with the guy with the class you know
what i mean he's like you know and put
the silent button i don't have the
silent button yes you do everyone has it
it's right here
convince me tom i will watch apocalypse
now man
it's on my list you got to see the redux
see apocalypse now redux now some people
like the theatrical cut better to be
fair i like the redux
it's longer but yeah but here's the
thing man if you can't get through
[ __ ] conan one you're never gonna get
through
you're never gonna get through
apocalypse now
i mean i don't know it's it's just kind
of like i guess i'm always because i
grew up
i mean one we grew up before the
internet two i'm a big
reader like i love to read and uh if
you're going to read a novel
you really need to kind of focus
because you're not going to focus you're
not going to know what the [ __ ] going
on you really have to like get all the
distractions and stuff so i maybe that
helps maybe that's kind of like
and like i said i don't really you know
i'm kind of the worst at doing this too
because look
in this office i have three computers i
have this one i have one over here and i
have a mac over here
and when i'm in here working if there
are
two or three things that i can have
going on at once
then i totally will because it'll get
done quicker it's like oh i need to
download this file over here i need to
like
upload this over here i need to write
this thing over here so i can do that
but when i'm consuming entertainment
i don't want anything else going on in
the i just want to concentrate on it
because otherwise
why but i'm not enjoying it if i can't
yeah give my full attention to it
yeah xanadu see uh apocalypse now redux
it actually has like an extra half hour
in there it kind of fleshes it out
it answered some of the questions that i
had from seeing the original one years
back
it's just it's it's a better movie
and you know it's approved of by
amelia's and uh oh what's his name
coppola they you know it's closer it's i
think it's a little closer to what they
wanted to talk about
and certain things make more sense in
the redux version
about where that surfboard came from
because in the in the in the uh
and remember just in the damn theatrical
theatrical cut you see the surfboard you
don't know where it came from but they
show you where it came from
in the redux they do yeah and it all
means something
tila says uh she has a very sad dvd
collection
she says i have more comedy dvds than
horror and horror is my favorite genre
i well nowadays i used to have like a
[ __ ] ton of horror dvds but
i don't have as many anymore just
because
you know it's it's much easier to get
them on streaming nowadays i do like to
own certain ones like if it's ones that
i'm going to watch over and over like
the shining
obviously but i don't know it's
i don't have a lot of comedies i'm
really really picky about i don't hate
comedies
but it's not my it's not my preferred
genre
it's probably right well it's not my
least favorite because my least favorite
is probably rom-coms
i [ __ ] hate those like all that and
all that kind of like
sappy lifetiming movie streaming that
one that we saw i thought was funny
which one
well that fat girl she went in another
dimension well now so i'm not saying
across
the board i'm just saying yeah that one
was super funny another drink
yeah that one was actually really funny
i do kind of like ruffle walls so you're
gonna take the glass or not yeah i think
you're gonna drink some more
no it's getting kind of watery um
you know it i don't know it just takes a
lot for a comedy i have
a strange sense of humor and
i don't know so it takes certain things
i like i like dark comedies
and i like some other kind of regular
comedies too but i don't know i just i
don't
i don't usually seek them out and like i
said i don't like
chick flicks i don't like rom-coms
usually unless they have some
[ __ ] up like dark comedy [ __ ] going on
in them
um i mean i don't know man it's i always
thought i was kind of get i would kind
of get sick of horror movies but i
i never have it's funny because i'll
watch
if he would let me i would probably i
would just watch horror movies all night
long i would just watch them one after
the other
or true crime i would watch true crime
documentaries one after the other it's
it doesn't bother me
and uh but you know we'll watch one
thing like i'll watch a true crime
documentary about [ __ ] some
horrible serial killer or something be
like can we watch something else
it's like can we watch something funny
it's like this is depressing and it's
like oh huh
are you depressed okay but okay
so and it he has a hard time like
watching
the same kind of thing in a row too much
and it doesn't bother me that much
like i said i used to when i used to
write more for my blog which i really
wish i had time to get back
more back into like i would watch
[ __ ] i would watch like four horror
movies
back to back and then like write about
all of them and it didn't bother me in
the slightest
so i don't know it's just it's something
i never get tired of even even though
some of them i don't really think of
them as particularly scary or anything
but it's just
it's just always something i've really
liked i always liked
horror [ __ ] i was like scary [ __ ]
and i'm not i don't i'm not really
interested in like other kind like
normal [ __ ] or
funny [ __ ] or i don't know i don't know
what it is
it must be some weird genetic anomaly
that i have but it's
it's just nothing that i ever get tired
of it doesn't bum me out it doesn't
depress me it doesn't do anything like
that
i just oh there we go
oh i forgot you had the hat on and then
you came in i'm like what the [ __ ]
who's that dude yeah well because it
looked really weird it looked like you
had horns for a second
to yes did you guys have a chance to
watch pandorum i haven't watched it yet
i wrote it down on my list though
but um isn't that a space movie i don't
remember
i wrote it down pandora yeah
sounds familiar mike says why does the
deer hunter never get
about you know what i want to do the
deer hunter too because i [ __ ] love
that movie
i haven't seen it for probably 20 years
i haven't seen in a long time but i
remember really digging at [ __ ]
christmas they're making him do damn
russian roulette and everything remember
that yeah
it's a great [ __ ] movie tila says i
can do horror back to back but then need
some levity
i guess i don't i don't know i just i
don't i don't really have that
like i said i can i can watch horror
movies for hours then i can go write a
horror story and then i can
i don't know it's just it doesn't bother
me i don't know what it is
i must have a problem
[Laughter]
oh man
xanada says cocaine cowboys is a good
documentary
we need to watch some more documentaries
yeah
pandora was on a spaceship with dinner
dennis quaid oh okay yeah yeah okay
i think i've seen it yeah a long time
ago
there's another good there's another
good science fiction movie
it was a little bitty movie it's really
good though low budget
it was um it never gets talked about if
you guys can find it
i i tried to look for it on blu-ray it
never got a blu-ray release
it was called hunter prey that was
actually much better than i was
expecting
yeah hunter prey was about these two
guys chasing this alien
through the desert and you find out
later that the dude
they're kind of like stormtroopers is
what they look like turns out those guys
in the stormtrooper masks are kind of
like reptiles
and the dude that they're chasing is a
human
he was a human captive that they had and
then you find out that
it's in the same universe as enemy mine
because he talks about the drax
the only guys ever saw an enemy yeah
that's right yeah so i remember that
kind of like an unofficial sequel to
enemy mind pretty good
and it was just made by some guys that
were special effects dudes hollywood
special effects guys
they had all these [ __ ] cool costumes
and they were just like man we can make
our own movie they went out to the
desert made their own movie
it was good i just have so much respect
for that um somebody said speaking of
that filthy gardener says have you guys
seen coherence yes it is
brilliant and like i said this is
exactly what i'm talking about
this was a dude that was basically he
got a bunch of his
uh friends that were actors together
that were all really good at improv
he used his own house and he did a
sci-fi movie but it's almost it's not
it's sci-fi in the sense that it's like
a weird time loop kind of story
and it's [ __ ] great and he let them
like kind of
improv their characters he kind of had
some plot points where he was kind of
like
hey you know you had an affair with this
person or whatever but then he just kind
of let him do their thing
and it came out really really good and
like the story is really cool like
there's this
dinner party and then they slowly start
to discover
that like a comet goes over if i
remember correctly
and i guess the comet being over there
makes like all of these realities sort
of exist in the same
place at the same time so all of the
people
at this house they have counterparts
no they don't really know how many
because it's not really made clear
but at other exact houses like in other
dimensional it's like it's really really
good um
but like i said that's a really good
example of
just a really great concept and a really
great um
you know really great actors really
great improv you know good writing good
you know plot development whatever and
you don't need a lot of money it's
filmed
pretty much in an entire house and in
front of the house and it's great
yeah um yeah i think hunter prey might
have been
might have been around 2009 2010 maybe
2011. somebody can look that up i don't
know it's called hunter prey
yeah it was really good yeah real good
good writing
um it's just made by dudes that made
costumes
for hollywood and it's spot on what are
you doing poop
what is she doing they didn't really
spend any money on it but they wrote a
good story and they executed real well
they uh shot it out in the desert with
some really good costumes
will you stop it oh she got the bo i had
a box that has like a
shampoo in it yeah she's trying to play
with it and she's like oh i'm gonna try
to get the box
don't play with the box pokey it's too
heavy it's too heavy she wants to go
outside
okay move outside it's kind of okay
that's what i gotta do
well come on it's not even dark out
charity wants to go outside
i don't know what the hell but uh yeah
so
oh man
i told him not to let her out until dark
but it's not
dark yet it's only six o'clock
all right yeah coherence was great
another one in that same vein was
triangle
also very good she said no it's not dark
enough see i told you she doesn't want
to go outside until she's like no
also i'm really mad because when i was
looking back
over my horror list
last week and i was like oh [ __ ] i
should have put in my
best of you know the last 21 years
i didn't put they look like people
and i'm really really mad that i forgot
because that totally would have been on
the list
i don't know which one it would have
knocked off but i guess because it
didn't come up like on the because i
just went through the wikipedia page and
stuff
like horror movies from this year that
year and it wasn't listed as a horror
movie i don't think
maybe because it's usually listed as a
thriller or
something but it's a psychological
horror movie for sure it's about a dude
with schizophrenia and he thinks all his
friends are demons
um and it's really really good i mean
really good i don't know where
i think i watch it on netflix but i
don't think it's on there anymore
it might be on some other streaming
service
triangle was on the ship yeah yeah that
was the one that was on the ship and
again that was another like time loop uh
time loop kind of thing where they kind
of found they got shipwrecked and then
they found this
ship and nobody was on it and then pete
somebody started shooting at him
and i don't want to spoil it farther
than that but it was like it was really
good it was like a time loop thing
you know yeah pandorum i think was the
one where
they were on a colony ship and um
guys were waking up out of hyper sleep
and had to run around inside the colony
ship they're being attacked by these
damn monsters
these aliens and it turns out the very
end that they had already arrived on the
planet a long time ago and the guy that
was running the ship was [ __ ]
torturing people
letting them out and having the [ __ ]
the monster so i can go after them and
they weren't monsters they were
humans uh that had been kind of like
infected with this mutagenic agent that
was supposed to be used to like
fertilize the new planet that's [ __ ]
weird
it's pretty weird it was a really really
i think that's that same one he's
talking about
i think it might have been called
pandora tila said another good list
would be scariest scenes in movies
i used to do a long time ago like i said
when i'm still writing
long-form stuff for my blog i did do um
some like a breakdown of some of my
favorite scenes
like in horror movies like what i
thought was were the creepiest ones and
a lot of ones that scared me when i was
a kid like i said the winkie's diner
scene from
mulholland drive which always freaked me
out um the ship from the tenant
particularly the one like i said the
tooth and the wall like where he sees
himself where he sees like all the way
goes in the bathroom it's all like
[ __ ] hieroglyphs all over that that
freaked me out
um and then it was like [ __ ] like if you
guys have seen the original
uh movie the eye i think it's a thai
movie i think it came it was pang
brothers it came out in 2002 i wanna say
and there's a [ __ ] terrifying scene
in that movie
with a girl in an elevator and if you've
seen the movie
you know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
it's really
really creepy so there's so that i
talked about that
i talked about um
stir of echoes the scene where the first
time when um
iliana douglas like uh when her
character
hypnotizes kevin bacon and he sees
she's trying to get him to like
visualize stuff so she
so sh he like uh visualizes like a movie
theater
just like and then everything's black
like the walls go black and then all the
seats are black and then
the [ __ ] uh screen lights up and it's
just the way they did it was
like super super creepy so that kind of
freaked me out
there was a scene in the first nightmare
on elm street which freaked me out too
which it's not the long arm thing
but it was the first time that nancy
sees
tina in the body bag like nancy is in
the english class and remember like that
guy's
reciting from the shakespeare play and
then like his voice goes to a whisper
which freaks me out
and then she looks over and sees tina
standing in the hall in the body bag
that freaks me out
i don't know why but uh yeah so i did a
whole series about
scary scenes seen in fright night where
amy's mouth is real big like that like
the uh
costume i did last halloween that scared
me when i was a
or like kid teenager what did what about
you what's your scariest what
what scene scared you in movies not none
of them
none of them well no when you were a kid
when i was a kid yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] man scene from salem's lot
with him wanting to there's a lot yeah
there's a lot of them when i was a kid
i mean just depends on what i what i
remember what i remember most
recently like i said we were talking
about the movie piranha
yeah that guy got his hand caught in the
damn fishing wire around the [ __ ]
boat
motor and all the piranhas ate his arm
off his hand off that i remember that
when i was a kid
um yeah i remember that there was [ __ ]
out of this giant spider invasion that
scared the hell out of me when i was a
kid and that was a [ __ ] cheesy ass
movie like when that girl had that spit
that tarantula went in that blender and
she blended it and drank it
that [ __ ] even stephen king mentioned
that yeah that freaked me out
um so yeah
although even though like i said giant
spider invasion it's it's a great
mystery science theater episode
and rifftrax did it too and that was
also really funny
but i love that
the spider that they made for giant
spider invasion it looks for all the
world
when it's eating a victim as though it's
stuffing the victims up its butt
it is i mean it really looks like he's
stepping off his butt it's not it
doesn't look like a mouth
well whoever made that [ __ ] it's a car
right yeah it's a car with spiders
there's more than one of them what i
thought was funny about that
about that though is that whoever made
that
thing did not understand arachnid bill
rabine
from wisconsin yeah he didn't know how
spiders were built
that thing had a head a thorax and an
abdomen
[ __ ] you know yeah it's like that's
an enzyme spiders
that's a totally different and they have
eight legs and insects only have six
yeah the body layout was all wrong on
the damn thing
they didn't know what they were doing
looked like a giant ant it's wisconsin
man they just like cobbled the [ __ ]
together
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] styrofoam and out of
and the one a couple of scenes i'm
pretty sure was a volkswagen
with carpets on it yeah i'm pretty sure
but like i said i had everybody in the
whole town running around [ __ ]
running from that thing
there's a i can't watch it nowadays
because like the that mystery science
theater episode is probably one of my
favorite ones because
mike that mike nelson the head writer is
also from wisconsin
so the so they had so much [ __ ]
ammunition
like going after this movie because you
know he's from there so it's like he
knew like the culture and [ __ ]
and it's just the [ __ ] [ __ ] so like
every time they have this mob of people
running around wanting to kill
this spider and they're like packers
like every [ __ ] time and it's just
like every [ __ ] time it makes me
laugh
and plus like the dude that's in it bill
rabine who
late like he made some pretty [ __ ] ass
movies gotta say
but he's actually kind of well he was a
dialogue coach
weirdly yeah um and he was actually
good enough at it that i think he was on
like the tonight show like he talked to
johnny carson and [ __ ] like that i want
to say
but um so what tila is looking at
piranha
no tila it's the original piranha yeah
because they've remade that
yeah you know they remade the omen too
yeah
okay i don't think i saw it though well
in 2006
maybe those movies were weird because
they were horror movies
well they weren't weird i guess there
were there was always like uh
i don't remember how i remember that
there were always kind of like sexual
innuendos sexual references and
like semi-nudity or nudity in them and
it was just
and it was always kind of like misplaced
it was just weird you know that
the edit and the timing of those real
cheap 70s movies didn't always work out
there was the funny one about the funny
thing i remembered about giant spider
invasion
piranha and piranha is that they were
always like
double features and around and around
that same time i think
i should have dropped it i think piranha
what are you doing
piranha opened with another movie that i
saw along with it
it was a i know she's laying on her back
over there with a little paws up like
that like hey
yeah no i'm being cute over here you
guys are not paying attention
piranha played with another movie i i'm
pretty sure it was the the one about the
snake i think it was called rattler
there was one called that's what it was
just a s yes a bunch of s's and i and
i think an exclamation exclamation point
i think and with that one there
they had a bunch of underage sex going
on about some 16 year old girl that was
screwing some dude
and she thought she killed him but it
wasn't it was the snake bite the snake
bit him and he died from that
but there was and the cops were trying
to settle her down says no no he didn't
you didn't kill him it was a snake bite
it was some weird [ __ ] and then it had
kind of like a billy jack
kind of [ __ ] character in that one
from sure i haven't seen it since i was
a kid
i haven't either but i saw it but it was
a long time ago
from what i remember there was a billy
jack type character if you don't know
who billy jack was he was just
he was a white native american he was a
white native american vietnam
army ranger who could do kung fu who
could do kung fu
right yeah and had a [ __ ] hat wore
jeans and he was kind of like the
original
walker texas ranger but he was a native
american white
ranger and [ __ ] new kung fu the 70s
were quite a 70s
and
he was kind of like the original chuck
norris in a way
and i think it and it might have been
related to walking tall in some way i'm
not sure
oh god jodon baker i'm not sure
but those who isn't that right b for t
pusser i have to go back and go look at
that was the name of that movie it was
yeah i don't remember how many s's it
was exactly like six or seven of them
yeah
you're right and i think it had an
exclamation point
because of course it's ridiculous as
[ __ ] but it was about as ridiculous as
piranha well like i said i love all
those nature run amok movies from the
70s they were so
so terrible and yet so [ __ ] awesome
i can't believe you people are taking me
down this direction i mean
orca yeah it was up there with both
freight [ __ ] great like i said i
think that
okay so i think probably i don't know
i don't i don't know if i want to say
kingdom of the spiders is my favorite
just because it has the shot in it
because empire the ants was good food of
the gods with the rats
loosely based on h.g wells story very
loosely based
tina says she loves them 70s [ __ ]
horror movies oh my god
she's seeing piranha and jaws yeah like
i said you got to see
did you did you see our show about about
um
was she on what about bug yeah yeah we
talked about that
i think you might have missed bug
there's there's a good 70s one called
bug
or bugs bugger bugs
and it was well made i don't think it's
pluralized is it's just called bug
i don't know if you saw that show or not
but [ __ ] you uh we talked about
this baby yeah just from the center of
the earth and they got hot and they
could seph
roaches who could set fires with their
butts yeah and then they could
crossbreed with other roaches
and then they they could talk and [ __ ]
yeah like not talk
like hey what's up they could talk like
tell exactly
yeah they just bugs came up on tubie
right
no bug it was on hulu hulu
yes some for free for who's not really
well if you have hulu you have to pay
you have to pay for home
it's good i pay for it it's good
actually the weirdest movie ever it had
the weirdest [ __ ] end
well i don't know if i'd go that far but
it is pretty weird i mean dude blew up
he jumped in the hole and blew up
that's how it ended spoiler alert
spoiler alert [ __ ] jumped in the hole
and blew up
and there's no reason why he blew up i
laughed so hard
i don't know i don't understand what
happened with that i was like making
jokes like
that's what happens when you jump into
the [ __ ] hole
he jumped down in the [ __ ] hole blew
up
and it said the end and i jumped up
jenny saw me i jumped that way no
no no he did yeah he's like i was like
yeah i was like dude he blew up
[Laughter]
they were going they were doing so well
and they just ended it one of these days
yeah uh one of these days i did mention
orca
mango i love i actually love that movie
um
and minerva has brought up phase four
which is actually a really good movie
i was like you know a lot of the ones
from the 70s you know with the [ __ ]
the swarm and all that kind of [ __ ] are
pretty cheesy but phase four was
actually
a good movie like by any measure so i'm
just saying
yeah um t says if roach is gonna shoot
fire out of its asses i'm right there
yeah yeah you're gonna love this movie
and it's taking place in california it's
taking place
where was that that an ocean side uh
i think it might around oceans old
school california back when
when a lot of it was dirt roads out in
the [ __ ] hills and fun fact the house
the garbage house where the mad
scientist lived was also the same as the
brady bunch
brady bunch house and i recognized it as
soon as i saw it i said they'll say some
other
bunch that's what i heard and she she
laughed me off and turned out no it was
i didn't laugh at you i just
i was just like i don't know i don't
remember the brady bunch
and then um another good one that you
might like t
if you like those 70s [ __ ] [ __ ] up
weird ass monster movies is that they
had one
i think it might have originally been
made for television but it was really
high quality
i i saw it on television i think it
might have been made for television but
it was like a big event
it was called gargoyles yeah that's
great
remember that yeah it's good i like that
movie it's about some
gargoyles come out of the [ __ ] center
of the earth they're trying to reclaim
and repopulate the earth
they're the same ones that were all on
the statues you know outside the [ __ ]
notre dame and [ __ ]
they looked just like that winged ones
and ones that didn't have wings and male
and female ones
and the main male one with the wings
look it looked kind of like the devil
he loved human women and he was going to
crossbreed with him remember that
of course he was yeah he's like there's
always one yeah yeah
yeah it's looking weird yeah trans
species baby yeah right
uh tila asked about let's scare jessica
to death we actually did a review of
that
oh gosh it's been a long time ago a long
time ago
yeah that was the one movie that always
like really kind of freaked me out it's
kind of a vampire movie sort of
yeah um t just added gargoyles just
added good reviews yeah gargoyles was a
trip
it's fun that's true that is a fun movie
yeah i
and honestly i really like a lot of
made for tv like they made a lot of
really good made for tv horror [ __ ] like
in the 70s
well like i said everybody knows duel
because you know steven spielberg the
car
that wasn't made for that wasn't made
for tv um you know steven spielberg
uh directed duel and it was based on
richard mathison but
if you guys did not know steven
spielberg also made another made for tv
movie back in the 70s called
something evil and that was pretty damn
good too i think it came out a little
bit after duel maybe
yeah um not as good as duel obviously
because that's a [ __ ] classic
but this one also kind of good and it
was kind of like a witchcrafty
like pennsylvania you know
people with like hex symbols on their
barns and that kind of [ __ ]
so it was like some witchcrafty satani
satani kind of stuff
and that was also very good um i think i
brought it up
before but probably one of my favorite
tv movies is
uh the strange possession of mrs oliver
with
sexy ass karen black i said it right
yeah that's right it always either
starts okay
karen black sexy ass or sexy ass karen
black it was
it's almost kind of like i like that
movie because for the whole time
it's i don't know i guess it's horror
but it's kind of like i don't know it's
more like a thriller but it has like
horror elements to it
there's some great like really creepy
imagery like with her like at a funeral
and stuff
but i don't and i don't want to spoil it
because i feel like a lot of people
haven't seen it
i had no [ __ ] idea what was going on
through the whole thing and then the end
of it
i was just kind of like like my i was
just like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] are you
[ __ ] kidding me right
like the ending of it was like batshit
crazy but like in a good way
i had no idea that that was coming i was
completely blindsided
maybe i'm dumb i don't know um but i
totally did not guess
where that [ __ ] was going i really
didn't but it's it's really good it's
you know did you see the car when they
called the car
yeah the car yeah i think they just
didn't they just put that on shutter or
something i just came out on blu-ray too
yeah yeah i got the blu-ray release
remember mm-hmm
yeah that's good this is [ __ ] about a
demonic car it came from hell that was a
[ __ ] weird
that's a weird one the car i kind of
feel like maybe
did that like rip off duel though yeah
it was like dual but it was second
paranormal
because duel was like a truck and a
truck driver and you never saw the
driver and you never knew what the
motive was
or you never you just saw his arm i
think and there was like no reason for
him to be doing
which like i said in a way kind of makes
it scarier because he doesn't
he's just doing the [ __ ] and he doesn't
she said she didn't see the car she just
saw the hearse
you got to see the car oh the hearse is
good i really like that i'm not seeing
the hearse
oh like i said i'm a big fan of and so
much of it is like forgotten
and there's one youtube channel and i
can't remember what it's called but
there's this one dude
and he has put up like a couple
hundred made for tv movies and like
forgotten movies from the 70s and so i
think he's got some 60 [ __ ] in there too
but there's so much good [ __ ] in there
like a lot of them are you know
okay marginally like okay but when
you're in the mood for those i don't
know there's something like really
kind of weirdly comforting about them
yeah i guess
well they were relaxing in a way and
they were written for
normal people well as normal as people
that
lived in the center yeah they would be
well they didn't have any deeper message
yeah most of the time if they did have a
message it was a very simple message it
wasn't
it wasn't any kind of intersectional
[ __ ] or anything you'd see now with
politics it wasn't they weren't
mean-spirited movies
they weren't trying to piss an audience
off or challenge anybody it wasn't any
kind of social thing or what it called
political thing
it was just how are we going to
entertain these [ __ ]
you know i mean that's really what it is
yeah what kind of [ __ ] story are you
going to tell these people tripping the
[ __ ] out
like you know can i just some of them
might have been anti-nuclear
like damination alley well a lot of them
were um
pro ecology because that was a big thing
in the 70s
yeah and went pouring chemicals all over
everything god damn it
yeah and what was funny is that he was
mutating all the animals
it was also kind of like they weren't
blaming anybody other than just [ __ ]
things in general
they were a lot of times the pro-ecology
ones were also religious
they were about [ __ ] with god's
creation and god's creatures yeah i
could see that they had a
so it was so i guess you could say they
appealed
even though it wasn't a very you know
some people would say it was more
divided then than it is now i don't
think so
they they appealed to people on the
right and the left if that was
if the right and left was actually a
thing like it is today i don't really
think
it really works oh yeah totally i think
it was kind of a little bit different
dynamic though back then
yeah the generations were different but
it appealed it
they appealed to everybody
was just laughing at brittany because
she was saying i just showed my kids the
movie rubber about the killer tire
because they didn't believe that it
existed it does indeed exist
what rubber that's what it's called it's
about a killer
tire okay like a killer car tire um
next you should show them death bed the
bed that eats
i remember that one although that's a
terrible terrible movement
although it is very funny when they feed
the bed um a bucket of kfc
yeah just saying is it that was such a
[ __ ] strange movie i was just
i was watching it because i said i gotta
watch deathbed the bed that eats come on
and i'm watching it and i'm just like
what kind of
there's like this is like the weirdly
the most weirdly exploitative
idea and then the person that made it
was like this kind of pretentious
oscar wilde reading person
and it was just like a really really
strange juxtaposition
i don't know like i said the 70s were a
[ __ ] weird time man
deathbed the bed that eats actually
might be on you can probably watch that
for free i would imagine
is i wouldn't advise it because it's
kind of boring
i mean so much potential there's so much
potential with that premise
and they just i i feel like it's kind of
unrealized
you know you know yeah
yeah all right oh yeah i don't know what
you told him i was just drinking
i lost track what was going on pat uh
yeah pat and oswald does it uh
does kind of a thing about uh death by
the bed yeah i know i saw that
um i thought it was terrible it was
terrible yeah
well like i said i feel like okay
somebody needs to do
a remake of it but
i don't know like maybe i'll do a remake
of it
nothing there well you have to well no
but you have to really get kind of the
tone right you have to
write a better backstory for the
deathbed you have to like have some more
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that happens with the
deathbed it's like it can't just be like
hey let's have sex on the bed and then
you get just absorbed into it and then
it's just like you're falling in the
water or whatever
because then it was the 70s and they you
know the movie cost about
three dollars to make what took him to
what 15 years to complete it
yeah yeah i mean you know he made it he
made that movie little by little with
his own money
and was making it up as he was going
along true i didn't really find i didn't
really
i remember seeing the movie and was kind
of pissed off that i had watched it
i mean yeah it had it's just a series of
scenes
it is yeah that's all it is yeah there's
not a lot of connectedness there's
nothing really connected to it
um i can understand what he was doing he
was just making a scene
after scene after scene of different
situations of why people would be
eaten by the bed but there was nothing
real there was
no real do was high well the thing about
it too was that the bed was like in an
abandoned house
which i think you need to get rid of
that right away because that's
you don't have like a pool of victims
right because you're just getting like
all these [ __ ] hippies wandering
through the woods
hey let's [ __ ] in this abandoned house
how often is that going to happen he
said
he said a lot of people don't like the
amnesia horror but i love the movie the
second one too
the amityville i love amityville horror
yeah i saw i saw the amityville [ __ ] in
the theater when it came out
uh my babysitter took it took me to see
it camp and
so i she had to have been what how old
at that time she had to be
it came out in 79 okay so i was nine
okay all right so she must have she was
old enough to get me into the movies in
california at that time
so she must been over 17. yeah okay i
would imagine well wait is it r
i don't know but there was california
they weren't real strict on that kind of
[ __ ]
especially if she went in there with a
bunch of cute girls she i think she was
probably closer to like 15 or 16 when
she took me
to 17 maybe maybe you're right i think
it might have been 17 back then
um but it's still 17. or if you're over
17 you can get into an art movie yeah
okay
okay and um that movie
emily horror was [ __ ] scary
they were scared yeah the pig thing
scared me yeah when i was little
in those days there was something about
there's something about seeing it on the
big screen doesn't quite translate
even to uh even to
uh my smart television because i saw it
on our on my big tv and hd
the transfer isn't that good it has kind
of a cheap
feel to it kind of feels like a made for
tv movie
it does yeah but it didn't feel like
that way that originally now i was just
a kid
but everybody loved that movie and it
was a sensation it was a big hit
and that book sold like a zillion people
yeah people talked about that even
though it was all a bunch of crap
people talked about that movie for a
long time
i can go back and watch that movie and
still enjoy it
yeah you know we watch it every couple
of years and it's like i still have a
good time with it
yeah i even you know what i didn't even
mind the remake all that much
yeah seeing jody up in the window so
like i said that that scared me
that scared me and um the scene where
uh where he had the dream that he axed
margot kidder that scared the [ __ ] out
of me
a lot what i always liked is that how he
fell through the steps and ended up
going into the damn black suit
there was a lot of scary [ __ ] in that
then the dog attacked him but then
helped get him out and then they [ __ ]
all escaped together and [ __ ]
the dog's name was harry yeah harry yeah
and lutz was brave he went back to go
save the dog
like a real man would do i'm gonna go
back again well yeah well like i said
even if like poltergeists are tearing my
house up you better believe i'm going
back in there to say pokey i'm gonna go
save pokey
yeah i'm not leaving her in there [ __ ]
that he ended up being [ __ ] [ __ ] you
demons falling into the toilet sludge
coming out anyway it was good and then
then
the way it ended you know the lutz left
they never went back you know
and it all just kind of strengthened the
damn lore of that case
it was another era pre-internet you
didn't have access to the witnesses
they'd show up on television every now
and then people thought it was real
i don't think i think it was a hoax uh i
think it was a hugs
there's two there were too many problems
with the story
yeah yeah the lutz is i think knew it
was a hoax but not everything that they
i think they all cooked it up like
together
yeah they wanted i mean yeah people did
a bunch of people did get shot in that
house that's true
you know we've we've dealt with stuff
you know we've dealt with the [ __ ]
paranormal scene written written written
books
a lot of people in that business are
there
they really honestly want to know what
the hell is going on
but there are some people out there to
this day
who will try to make up a story hoping
that it's going to have the response
that that the amityville horror case had
as if it's
1979. well people it's too diffuse
nowadays
you just can't you can't command the
same uh portion of the population that
you could back then
because there's too many other options
too many other things
we no longer no longer live in a
centralized top-down
market or a top-down world everything is
parallel
diffuse and spread out which is actually
better
because they can't force you to watch
anything anymore
and ambivale horror came from a time
when there was like four television
stations and cable was new and there
wasn't a whole hell of a lot on cable
no so if you had a movie
and the movie referenced to book you
would sell millions of damn books
yeah cuz what the [ __ ] else were you
gonna watch or read that was kind of the
whole that was it
now you as a writer might only get 10
cents on a book maybe a dollar on a book
but still that's a million dollars
well yeah if you sell like several which
that book did yeah
i mean back then if it was some
paranormal [ __ ] particularly in the 70s
if it was like some paranormal that was
like kind of believable and they're like
based on a true story oh man
yeah but that will not happen again the
market is totally different
books are totally different there will
never be another stephen king again
you know he he happened because the
publishing industry was so different
back then
if you had a hit you could get another
hit and another hit and another hit and
another hit and you could just keep
having millions of
stephen king but really not a lot of
people have that yeah
i mean some people do obviously still
but
and then he had great same publishing
houses that are willing to get those
hits
so in a way the old stars
of the old order that's what i want to
put it they were kind of artificial
creations
riding on the back of industries
and i guess you could say platforms
that'd be a good modern way
they're riding on the back of platforms
that no longer exist
the publishing industry is not what it
was it doesn't command the power it used
to
it's all online now which means that
everyone is competing
it's good and is bad because now a
person like jenny
can compete without any kind of damn
gatekeepers you don't have to lay out a
bunch of money there's no kickbacks
there's no weird
contracts you can just write a book and
get a couple bucks off the damn book
when you sell it
and it's more than you don't have to
sell sell a million copies anymore
you know you can sell a few thousand
copies and it made it worth
the while you know and then you do it
all over time
since they're all print on demand you
don't have to rent a warehouse and order
two million [ __ ] copies and have that
[ __ ] sitting up in warehouses
for the next five years selling them one
at a time so it's just not
it's a lot more efficient well and but
it's a trade-off because
it's the thing where back in the old
days if you had if you could get an
agent and then you could get a publisher
the publisher
would front money would you know
advertise the [ __ ] would put you on tv
you would do all this other stuff so
it would like amp up your sales and
you'd end up making more per
book yeah but then there was a big
infusion of money like
oh by the way here's four hundred
thousand dollars you know which is the
front
for his first novel yeah that wasn't the
first thing he'd written he had had
short a lot of short stories published
he started out doing
short stories and like skin mags you
know what i mean because that's kind of
what you did you just publish horror
stories and skin mags yeah
and then uh you know so he had published
a bunch of short stories and i guess he
submitted his first uh
novel which was carrie and uh they gave
him a 400 000
advance he was living in a [ __ ]
trailer with his wife and they had a
baby or two
and you know yeah he said he was writing
on a typewriter a cry he didn't have a
desk he just had like a [ __ ]
uh like a plank of wood on the
typewriter that he'd like put in his lap
that was
like right so you know it it did happen
but i i just feel like it may be
i don't know it doesn't really happen
the same way so jumped in
yeah yeah mango said that was the coke
money yeah he did
a lot of that probably went up his nose
right yeah sadly
yeah he said there was like a there was
a stretch where he didn't remember like
a bunch of the books that he wrote
which is crazy man it's like how man
i have two or three drinks it's like
there's no way i could write a [ __ ]
novel that would make any sense
come on now i mean if you can be like
coked out of your gourd so much that you
don't even remember it later and you
could write like a [ __ ] thousand page
novel
props to you man i'm just saying yeah
t-axis just two sucked but exorcist
three was great
yeah we did a review on exorcist three
actually i feel like it's really
underrated
yeah now some people are saying that
like the other amityville movies were
cool too and i remember
seeing i think i saw amityville i'm sure
i've seen amityville 2.
i might have also seen amityville 3
because they were on cable a lot back in
the day but i
don't remember that much about them so
and a lot of people are saying that
those were actually
good so maybe maybe i should check those
out again maybe we should do
they've made although we can't see all
the amityville movies because i think
last time i checked i think they've made
19 amityville movies
at this stage yeah um
you know the poor people that [ __ ]
live in that house still
although didn't they move it i think the
house has been moved and they don't have
those windows anymore
they changed the windows they didn't
want people because they were sick of
people coming by there
even though everybody still knows where
it's at there's the internet
you know what i mean it's ridiculous it
is uh yeah
somebody was talking about uh stephen
king's
coke addiction yeah he went on a lot
about that
um it's just it's mind-blowing to me
how much that he wrote um
that he doesn't remember that just
[ __ ] kills me
well it came out of this [ __ ] right
side of his brain i guess
out of the damn subconscious and stuff i
i will admit that once
because like when i'm thinking about it
when i was reading um
on writing which if you're a writer uh
you know you might wanna
it's it's really good it's it's part
memoir and then part
kind of writing advice i guess sort of
um but not in a sort of condescending
way um
it almost kind of made me what it's like
maybe i should get coked out
maybe that helped me it cost too much
money it would yeah that's like all my
[ __ ] money would be gone
but it does kind of one thing that
stephen king i will give stephen king
credit for this
like i said i grew up reading his stuff
um i think
to be a writer i was more inspired by
clive barker
because he was like way weirder and like
the [ __ ] that he came up with just
you know his imagination was like really
um inspiring to me but one thing that
stephen king
said that actually um resonated a lot
with me
was that and i think he wrote about it
in on writing
was that he's like oh i never have an
outline
he's like i just have um an idea
like an idea of you know a situation
he's like i think of a couple of
characters i think of a situation
what if all of these people were trapped
in a grocery store and there were all
these like monsters outside like from
another dimension
like he'll think of that and then he's
like and i don't write anything else
down i don't make an outline and i'll do
a plot synopsis i don't do anything i
just sit down and start writing
and he's like and i just [ __ ] i let
it go and i'll think about it
and to me that was like you know as a
20-something-year-old
person that was revelatory because to me
i had always thought and i'm i'm you
know i'm kind of like an organized
person
i try to like get all my [ __ ] together i
make lists every day of what i gotta do
and everything and so i had always tried
to make outlines
of my stories like i'd have an idea and
then i'm like okay well i'm gonna do
this and then this person's gonna do
this and so
i have this big plot outline done like a
big chart and everything
and then i would get like halfway
through the [ __ ] and then i'd get kind
of lost or i'd get bored with it or
something like that and i would never
finish anything
and so him saying that made me actually
i was like maybe i should try it maybe i
should try that
just not even don't worry about it just
come up with an idea and just start
writing [ __ ] and just see what happens
and it worked
i mean it might not work for everybody
but i feel like i was getting so
bogged down in the details
and so worried about how is this going
to resolve itself you know how am i
going to do this and that
i think i had a weird thing when i was
younger that i didn't realize
that i could go back after it was done
and fix it yeah and i know that's stupid
but i don't think that ever really
occurred to me in any meaningful way
until i was older but it's like you know
you can just write the whole thing just
like write a draft of it
and then you can go back later and like
tweak things and make it seem more like
you
meant to do that jenny spends all day
working and she's either working on her
own stuff or doing things for on
contract for other people
i spent a lot of the time watching other
youtubers who track
um corporations like i'm really big into
what's happening at disney with the
mandalorian
and just uh of things that are happening
in hollywood
and i'm just convinced and also in
politics
super politics on the government around
the government on the global level and
everything
we're in between two different eras the
era of the old era
is ending in a new era is coming
and it's going to be very shocking to
people who built their lives
on the old institutions because the old
institutions aren't going to make it
but it's going to be very liberating to
people like jenny and me
who can freewheel and have skills that
can be used on the internet because
it's going to be people like us
individual creators and you people are
the future
the big the big industries are not going
to make it
um they're too big they're too clumsy
just like apocalypse now they're like
snails crawling across the edge of a
straight razor
that's what they're like they're not
they can't maneuver enough they can't
bring a product to to market quickly
enough and they're all being attacked by
their own fans
because they listen to fans on twitter
the more popular you are
the bigger you are as a target then
there's all these mobs cancel culture
mobs coming after them
it's all very bad for business and
the old hollywood and the old way of
producing things
for them they kind of had kind of like a
soviet
mindset where art was also politics you
don't bother to make a movie unless it's
going to be politics and important they
call it an important movie
well when you do that you're throwing
yourself into a
to a low level [ __ ] civil war
and people will tear it apart doesn't
matter which side you pick just picking
aside is enough to make yourself a
target
and they're going to tear those big
corporations apart it doesn't take long
they don't have unlimited money i think
disney's only going to last two years
the way that it's going i've been
watching the stock market and what's
happening with them
and what happened at that investors
meetings and what they did
to the [ __ ] star wars property they
destroyed that [ __ ] property
that's because they didn't have a
unified vision of it
and they didn't want the old fans
they're like oh we don't want the old
fans well that's where all your money
was they were buying ones buying all
that damn merchandise
it had to be something for everybody
there and they had to
they can't be artistic anymore they're
going by
uh what certain councils are saying
based upon
market research and it just it just
waters it down
so their product is gonna [ __ ] suck
the future is gonna be these movies like
i just talked about
like hunter prey which is a little
[ __ ] movie
made by a couple of guys it's a [ __ ]
excellent movie and it's for a small
audience that can appreciate it
it's going to be these little
independent
films that's the future and it's going
to be custom made
to fulfill a certain market niche
you're not going to see these big
blockbusters and they know it they know
all that [ __ ] is
technologically obsolete that's why they
pulled the plug on amc
uh they're pulling their own plugs on
everything because they know that
there's
that that that's over uh there's a lot
of things that the
civilization is built on that is now
technologically obsolete like
things like cities cities aren't going
to make it
not not long the heart of a city is
office buildings
what the [ __ ] do you need an office
building now anymore
the rest of the city just supported
those office buildings they're all
working from home now
so it's only a matter of time you know
that the future will not
look like the 1900s it just won't and
and they're panicked they're scared but
us as little people and if you're
listening to us then you're a [ __ ]
one
another one of the little people we
don't have anything to lose
from that system going under i've been
analyzing it
we don't really only have things to gain
those corporations are
just not it's not going to be a top-down
soviet-style or old-school
american-style economy anymore
it's going to be a network economy based
upon
who you know what you're offering and
how quickly you can get bring it to
market and
how good is the quality that's what's
going to be that's what's happening now
well tilo was saying that you know some
there are some
youtube channels of just like people
studying and it's just like they get
tons of views and i was gonna say [ __ ]
like this morning i was watching a five
minute video
of a dude brushing a long hair cat yep
and the cat
farting around and not wanting to try to
take the brush away
all right now check this out check this
out i have to go back in time
to the mindset of an nbc television
executive from the 1970s
and i would have to show him i have to
see that situation through his eyes
as an nbc television exec from the 80s
the 70s would see
jenny watching a cat video for 20
minutes
and he would lose his [ __ ] [ __ ]
because he's like
that's seven million dollars worth of
air time that she just watched
of somebody combing yeah why we should
have been able to sell her something
during that time
those arrows that that era is gone
everyone can film
things now everyone can learn
and it looks good yeah you could make
your own movie now for a fraction of
what a hollywood studio
yeah and people are and people are doing
it
so that's not all of them are good
that's going away
all right here's another thing that's
going away a lot of people are having a
hard time wrapping their rounds and
head around it universities universities
are going away
where the hell would you you have to
understand the history of what made a
university that was during the 1700s
and it was a religious parachute you
went there and you bought a ticket
to go to heaven and you learned a little
bit of things and it was a almost kind
of like a religious institution it was a
way of buying yourself permission
to go into the higher class back in the
day you could go to one
get a degree in something and get a job
in one of these corporations well
they've outsourced all that
if you go to the university now your
chances are you're not going to get a
job
not unless maybe you're a doctor and
even in there and hard science hard
science and math that doesn't really
make a lot of money
the guys that were really making money
with those university
educations were guys that were in
finance because they could go won't go
on wall street
go work in a [ __ ] big bank yeah they
made a lot of money
not so much science and then if they
wanted science done they'd contact some
dude in india
who [ __ ] he didn't have the college
debt so he's not sure he's not
charging as much all that shit's going
away i mean
everyone now has access to the internet
which is the sum of mankind's knowledge
and you can buy training and education
over the internet
yeah for relatively cheaply for cheap
and then you can use it
use it on your own you don't need to
work for somebody else to use it they're
going to steal your money
that's the future if you look t i'm
going i'm pointing taylor you're going
look the biggest indicator of poverty in
the united states if you look at it
has nothing to do with the race it's
whether or not you have that piece of
paper
whether or not you had that college
degree that was the big indicator of
whether or not
you were making money or not that
college degree
i never got one i [ __ ] walked away
from college [ __ ] at the end of my
first year
i knew that [ __ ] was stupid i also knew
that that [ __ ] was going away but then i
kicked myself in the ass because
i lost a bunch of jobs that i could have
got
i was smart enough to get them i had the
skills to do it but because you didn't
have that [ __ ] piece of paper right
there they were kind of like
a [ __ ] you get out of here and then they
give it to a person who's dumber than me
but they do have that piece of paper
it's like entering into a club i'm glad
that that shit's falling apart
jenny's got a degree but you got you got
that uh uh
privately right was didn't have
something to do with uh graphic design
type degrees
yeah i got a graphic design degree yeah
and you you know and you can actually
make money with that
i do make money she makes money with
that that is one of my three income
streams
i challenge you to go get a degree in
underwater basket weaving and [ __ ]
sociology and see tell me if you get a
job with that not anymore
he's going to have a whole bunch my
friend my friend jason [ __ ]
granthars knows exactly who he is i
don't want to
well yeah i didn't say the last name
he's like couple hundred thousand
dollars in debt
[ __ ] he's part of academia he's
got all kinds of [ __ ] papers
published and [ __ ] like that
all of his intellectual [ __ ] buddies
loving that dude's [ __ ]
installing cabinets he's installing
kitchen cabinets
ed was just a bad he's a smart dude but
that was a bad investment
very bad investment just saying i mean
well the thing about it is that like no
one really knew and they didn't know
yeah i didn't know i thought i was going
to lose out nah it's a good thing
i was going for that [ __ ] business
degree i'm just glad i didn't take out
any loans i was
i took out a loan and i was going for a
business degree in accounting
all right and [ __ ] as time went on
that that would have all excel made all
that [ __ ] obsolete
if you can run excel then you don't need
any of that [ __ ] they got accounting
programs that are [ __ ] better than
any man
well i don't know in a way it's like i
know how like
it sucks for a lot of people but i'm
kind of the kind of person that i've
always been like this
is that i really hate i guess because
i'm kind of a control freak
i really hate anything that i have to do
um
whether it's publishing whether it's
doing the show whether it's [ __ ] what
is
anything um i don't want to entrust it
to someone else
because they will [ __ ] it up or they
won't do it
in a timeline that i find expedient um
and i like waiting for people i'm really
impatient
so basically i'm just like [ __ ] i would
rather
do everything myself and just be
stressed out all the time
than give my [ __ ] to someone else to do
it
yeah i mean i really really don't like
having to
you know what i mean she wants to go
outside because i mean you know he said
sometimes well why don't you get
somebody to help with the show
or like edit the thing and it's like it
would be cool because it would save me
some time to do some other [ __ ] but then
when i think about it i'm like
i don't know man it's i don't really
like
i don't know i don't know if it's
because i don't trust other people and i
don't think they're gonna do it right or
or they're not gonna do it in time it's
like and i'm gonna have to keep nagging
them it's like i don't really
i honestly i like to deal with other
people as
little as possible and if it's something
that
um you know is something that i created
like the show or like my books or
something like that
it's really really hard for me to let go
of any
because a couple times i had a couple
novels published by
you know a another publishing house like
a smaller publishing house
several years ago and even though the
covers they did for the novels were fine
um
i was really really like annoyed because
i wanted to do the layout i wanted to do
the cover i wanted to do but of course
they're not gonna let me do it because
they have their own in-house people that
do it
and like i said they were fine they were
lovely but
at the same time i was kind of like yeah
that's not what i would have done
you know yeah so honestly the two novels
that um
that i wrote a long time ago that were
published by another publishing house
uh the rights have reverted to me at
this point so i'm gonna republish them
with my own layout and my own cover just
because i'm [ __ ] like that
[Laughter]
graham postulates to possibly take all
those office buildings and
and convert them into um apartments
yeah uh that's what they said about all
those dead malls
it's not really how it works because
banks are involved
and uh things like bankruptcies are
involved and they can actually find
ways because they're the ones that also
write the laws
they will find ways to profit
and make money off of demolishing things
and tearing them down
that's like what they do with those
malls so no they'll they'll they'll tear
them down
i'll tell them down it'll end up looking
like uh like detroit you know
a good bit of detroit that i remember is
now gone it's just returned to the
wilderness
you'll see sidewalks and roads but no
buildings anymore
it'll look like that it'll um
kind of look like a future more like
something i don't have tom cruise movies
where
everything kind of looks like suburban
because the things that the cities were
offering
no longer exist so you're and there's
somebody here just said some woman says
her company's making all kinds of profit
because they have them all working at
home now
you don't need it's not 1950 anymore you
don't need a goddamn slave driver
walking around between all the desks
cracking a whip on people get to work
fill out that [ __ ] 214 fill out that
like from [ __ ] office space you don't
need that anymore the computers got rid
of all that
you either do your work or you don't if
you don't do your work to hire somebody
else online to do it
yeah you don't even hire anybody in the
world yep you don't need bosses
that was the thing go see office space
everyone's seen it i think
if you haven't seen that that was the
business world that i lived in [ __ ]
coming out of the army to fix [ __ ]
sucked
all that stuff got exported to india it
was gone
um and it was just and the the middle
management the upper management they
spent most of their time
worried about becoming obsolete and
losing their jobs and they did they they
went well because they didn't they
didn't do anything they
do anything they didn't do anything they
walked around and made sure other people
worked
because they would have done that they
would have done it anyway but i mean i
would have
that was the that was a 1950s
office culture that took a long time for
it to die off
where you force a [ __ ] to work
even though they were going to do that
they were going to work anyway
right it's ridiculous but that i mean
i've always been before
this is why i was always well yeah and i
don't like that i don't like that in any
shape or form
and it's kind of like this is why all
the jobs that i had i was
always really uncomfortable i get really
resentful
when i have other people this is why
people don't like
managers and [ __ ] because they don't
know what your job entails especially
like if you do graphic design like i do
usually your manager or the person above
the manager
uh is somebody that doesn't know
anything about the technical they don't
know how to use photoshop they don't
know
anything like that so having somebody
that doesn't know
what your job is tell you what your job
is
is very tiresome um
so that was something that always kind
of like got on my nerves a lot
because they would tell they would say
dumb [ __ ] it's like well you just have
to do this that and the other thing i'm
like no that's not how it works
but thank you for your input which was
really
useless you know yeah jesus you work
from home
they love it no commuting no mark
imagine here's another thing t that i
[ __ ] like about it
you're not spending money commuting yeah
because i used to spend
[ __ ] i used to spend 80 on gas
burning up your car putting miles on
your
car burning up [ __ ] your gasoline to
go to their [ __ ] job
and it's [ __ ] you could have done from
home well this is what i was trying to
tell old boy
that's a huge impact on [ __ ] the real
estate
all right commercial real estate's gonna
[ __ ] plummet
they're gonna sell all that [ __ ] off
it's not gonna be worth anything
well guess where all that [ __ ]
commercial real estate is
downtown downtown in those cities
most of that city its infrastructure was
built to serve
those those [ __ ] buildings
now there are there are apartment
complex down there
that people that worked in those
buildings lived in and those might
stay but over time those people will
move out into suburban areas
and then you have all the services the
electrical services the fire departments
the police
all of that was in those cities really
because of those apartment buildings
excuse me because of those office
buildings that's the lynch pin
of all those cities well guess what
there are whole political parties built
upon high-density [ __ ] cities
when those are gone what's going to
happen to them they're panicked
they're [ __ ] scared they're very
scared
i think that's why you're starting to
see it's going to start to creep towards
some kind of
technological based [ __ ] they're
going to try to get
authoritarian eventually because
whenever you threaten their money when
you threaten the money of the power
structure
they become authoritarian they don't
give a [ __ ] about that right that right
and left [ __ ]
that right and left political dynamic
that's for poor people to think
to believe in they don't believe in it
you go up high enough
they own both of those so it's dangerous
you know it's very dangerous i'm worried
you know i try to keep myself [ __ ]
calm because uh
they're not very good they're not
smarter than you
you when you analyze who it is they're
not very competent and they're not very
smart
most of them got into their positions by
luck or because they were related to
somebody
so they can't really out thank you and
you will see it coming when they do what
they do
they've never really won long term
they'll make little
they'll make little wins but
overall i think the people will win out
they're not gonna be able to control
these people you know i'm just
wanting freedom freedom that's all i
care about i do my thing you do your
thing
i don't like to be told what to do
jenny's the same way jenny does not like
to be told what to do
no i really do yeah i don't like telling
other people
yeah i don't want to tell other people
why should i have to tell some other
[ __ ] what to do he should know
you know what i mean he should know what
to do and but then when he's coming to
[ __ ]
destroy my life or take things from me
or to tell me how to live no i'm not
about that
i'm a living let live kind of guy
you know yeah you know i've always do
the same way
well like i said i've been like that
since right uh birth probably right
i just don't trust them i just don't
trust any of them you don't
get to a position of power and wealth by
being a good person this is something
i've learned personally in my life by
knowing those people
in other countries mostly brazil they
did not get there by being good they got
there by being bad
that's why they got there that's how
they got there
yep it's just like the animal kingdom
that they got there by the animalistic
way they ate all their competition
that's what they did yeah everybody's
talking about how nice it is to work
from home
i mean you know santa is saying i know
not everyone can obviously there's like
actually a large segment of the
population that can't work from home
obviously
but i actually started working from home
not by choice uh way before any of this
started i think it was
july 2016 because i got laid off
and basically i had to go on
unemployment for a little while and then
it ran out
uh so tom was kind of like well
while you have some unemployment why
don't you
you know why don't we try to beef up the
podcast why are you trying to like get
some books out want to you know just
make a husband
get to get some income stream going and
then he like turned this into an office
and
i started doing audio books and stuff it
took a while there was like some scary
there was
a a scary time period there like uh
you know probably till the end of 2016
maybe into 2017
and uh you know it was pretty scary i
didn't have a lot of money and
it kind of sucked but after a while it
kind of worked itself out like
like i said i'm not i have enough to pay
my bills
and that's about it but
i mean in a lot of ways like people are
saying it's like you don't have to
commute i used to the job that i had
before i got laid off was only about
eight miles from here so it was only
about a 15 minute drive
but still it's like it's a pain in the
ass it's a pain in the ass having to get
up early you gotta
you know [ __ ] get dressed put makeup
on you gotta drive somewhere
yeah you gotta go you gotta deal with
[ __ ] the public and they suck and
it's just kind of like
thank you thank you everybody
everybody's agreeing with me that's
right thank you everybody you know the
deal
we just wanna everybody just wants to
live their lives
nobody wants to be told what to do and
that's just yeah i mean as long as
you're not like
doing [ __ ] to like [ __ ] encroach on
other people's [ __ ] yeah of course
you should be free to do whatever you
want to do but you can't deny the
freedom of others you can't go around
[ __ ] other people over and taking
[ __ ] from them and
[ __ ] that they work for and you know the
[ __ ] that they built you
leave people [ __ ] alone you know what
i mean if you come for me you're gonna
pay
okay but the thing is i'm not coming for
you you know and that's just
i'm too lazy to come yeah we got [ __ ] we
gotta do it's not working
i just want to hang up my office and
drink coffee and get my [ __ ] done if
you're a good person you're too busy
then to [ __ ] with other people it's just
the way it is well that's what i'm
saying yeah i'm always i'm a very
you know i'm i'm a very introverted
person i'm always just kind of like
this is how introverted i am i was it's
weird because i was actually thinking
about this this morning
i was out on my hike this morning i
think i did a five mile
earlier it was about seven o'clock in
the morning and
you know i see a lot of the same people
every morning
because they all walk i'm walking or
they're jogging or whatever
some of them i wave to some of them i
don't um because
you know what but it's like weird
because when i'm walking
i'm always kind of like looking at the
person ahead i'm like is this a person
that i normally wave to
i hope not because i don't know it
stresses me out having to like
[ __ ] wave to people because when i'm
just like out
walking on my [ __ ] i just want to do my
[ __ ] i have my headphones on i have
music on
i don't really want to have to think
about anybody else it would
i would be happy if there was nobody
else on the path
but i know that that's not realistic
it's not crowded or anything
because there's a lot of people do live
around here it's just very suburban
and a lot of people walk their dogs and
ride their bikes and [ __ ] but
i don't know i was i always kind of
think about it's like every time i see a
person i'm like i get like anxiety for a
second
like do i have to wave to this person
[ __ ] that's not the friendly people out
there anyway
i know they're all nice and and like a
lot of them actually are cool
although there's this one weirdo that is
out i haven't seen him for a while
but um one he always walks in the wrong
side
you know because you know how on the
path it's like everybody just kind of
does
like you know you would do if you were
driving a car yeah
so you're on the same side of the road
all the signs are pointing the same side
as if you were driving a car
so you're doing that and he's always
jogging or walking
on the wrong side right yeah i don't
know what his name is so i just call him
always on the wrong side of the road guy
um and so like i'll be walking and i'm
just like oh [ __ ] here's this [ __ ]
again and he's because he's coming up
this way
and then he does the same thing every
time he goes like this he'll be jogging
or walking
and he'll be on the wrong side and then
he'll look and he'll see somebody coming
like me or whatever
and then he'll go like this he'll go and
then he just
he what he walks over to the other side
and i'm like
why do you not just be on the right side
to start like why are you he wants you
to look at him
and then like one morning and i've seen
him like talking to some people too
because one morning
because normally i wear sunglasses
because i'm a [ __ ] vampire
and i can't stand the sun in my [ __ ]
face at seven o'clock in the morning
one morning it was dark because it was
real cloudy so i didn't have sunglasses
on
um and i don't you know i don't have
makeup on when i'm going out so i don't
have any eyebrows so
that's a little weird too so maybe i'm a
little weird looking so i have eyebrows
but so i'm out there and i'm just like
walking by to my own [ __ ] business
and then this dude is like he's walking
this way and then he's like oh [ __ ] i
gotta go to the other side i'm like yeah
do that
so then he goes over there and then he's
like talking to me he's like gesturing
and i'm just like [ __ ] me what is what
do you want
wear your sunglasses i'm like it's
dark out yeah and then i just kept
walking
so he didn't talk to me anymore because
he probably thinks i'm a douche and i
don't really care
i saw him like talking to somebody was
like a little muslim girl like walking i
see her all the time too
and he was like talking to her i saw it
like way up there
and he's like started talking to her and
i could see her kind of like backing
away
get the [ __ ] away like this and i'm just
kind of like oh man i need to get up
there and save that girl cause maybe
he's being obnoxious
because i didn't know what he was saying
i couldn't hear him and um but he had
moved on by the time i got up there but
i could see her body language she was
just kind of like
not just kind of like yeah i know um i
don't think he's like a
you know a murderer or anything but he's
for sure weird i don't know he's got
like a weird thing
and i don't understand this always
wanting to be on the wrong side of the
road there's there's been like a couple
of guys
that do that and i'm not entirely sure
i'm like do you just enjoy
being a pain in my ass or a pain in
everyone's ass is that
you just kind of trying to get attention
it's like a little power game or
i'm like okay yeah zach i think we're
going to win i mean
think about it there aren't very many
corporations
making these making products all right
they're trying to market them like
for instance like like disney they don't
have that many products
and they're trying to market market them
to a large number of people
just off of one platform disney plus
that's not a very good business model
how the hell are they going to compete
against
millions and millions of other people
small creators
that almost hour for hour can compete
with them
and their their overheads are huge all
right
i mean you know cost them millions and
millions of dollars
to make an episode out of one of these
damn series
all the while they have to float the
overheads
not only from these movie projects but
these hotels and these parks and those
hotels and the two in the parks that
they have evidently aren't doing too
well
and you would think well disney's not
going anywhere that's a multi-billion
dollar
industry a couple billion dollars is
nothing to them
that that's their overheads you know
you only have to [ __ ] hit hurt them
by 20 percent
and they wouldn't be able to make their
overheads they'd have to start doing
things like
closing parks or closing hotels
and very quickly as [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
can can unravel they got very high
overheads
uh corporations are not safe you know
what i mean just because it has a lot of
money
doesn't mean that it will be here
forever i mean you know i'm old enough
to have seen things just [ __ ]
vanish that i thought would never vanish
amc being one of them
other ones [ __ ] like enron and not only
did it vanish
it vanished in disgrace you know there's
a lot sears sears is gone i never would
have imagined sears being gone
[ __ ] 20 30 years ago as a kid that
just seemed like that was just rock
solid
sears been around for a hundred years
sears will always be here no sears went
broke
stairs went broken it looked like [ __ ]
on its way out [ __ ] crummy ass stores
no no nothing's permanent the center
does not hold
things fall apart
sophie's saying maybe he's from another
country where they drive they're driving
well see i thought that too um that was
actually the first thing i thought and
some people i'm willing to give them a
pass
because i feel like oh you know maybe
they're from you know the uk or
you know somewhere they drive on the
other side okay fair enough or maybe
they have a reason for it
but i don't know this guy
he did talk to me one time and he sounds
like an american
so i don't know i think he's just a
weirdo he has like a lot of weird
and i think it was this morning or
yesterday morning when he was talking to
that muslim girl and i was just kind of
like
i was i was too far away like i saw them
up there and i was just kind of like
maybe i should go help her because
she really looks like she's like dude
[ __ ] the [ __ ] there's too much
too much damn battle time no dude you're
tripping looking uh
four drug fourth drawer down also
brought up pan am
pan am was another one i thought would
never disappear
my grandfather used to work for pan am a
long time ago they don't these companies
don't last
you know some of them all those the
[ __ ]
the industries that damn ran the united
states through most of the night
most of the first half of the 1900s was
the railroads actually
the late 1800s too and now they're just
they're
a shadow of them for themselves when the
last time you ever worried about the
damn railroad i mean industries come and
go it takes a long time
you know a railroad back in the day
could make or break you
they could just stop they could just if
you pissed them off they wouldn't stop
at your town and that would
starve your entire food there goes all
your food there goes all your money and
all your jobs
if you pissed them off they just
wouldn't stop not really the case
anymore yeah well the internet
certainly these internet platforms like
facebook tries to do that
oh we're not going to [ __ ] let you
post anymore
none of that shit's going to work in a
couple years because they're going to
make a bunch of other platforms
well like i said it's the thing about it
though is that
that's not really uh an exact
equivalence because
everybody needs food nobody needs to
post it on facebook
no no but it's of just a flow of
information yeah sure flow of
information that's what i'm talking
about
no the railroads were far more powerful
yeah they could make your town
vanish yeah exactly and they did
literally they did it i mean they did
yeah i'm just saying like if facebook
was like yeah you can't post on here
that's not really a tragedy because like
oh i can't
like [ __ ] cry on facebook anymore yep
start a blog you can see what i was
referring to though no i'm just saying
that it's like not really
what i was referring to was uh the fight
that australia had
with do you know about the australia and
facebook a little bit i couldn't believe
that that's what i was talking about
here
talking about australia wouldn't allow a
new cert or
[ __ ] australia wanted facebook to pay
them for the news that
had been posted on there facebook said
no
so uh and then facebook shut off the
australian news
but eventually the [ __ ] australia
buckled to him which that's like
something the railroad would have done
achieve it's about malls yeah malls are
um
malls are another dying art why the hell
would you want to pay retail for little
trinkets
that are [ __ ] totally way overpriced
and it's [ __ ] you don't need anyway
you know might have been something you
thought you needed back in the 80s or
the 90s
but you don't need anything that they're
selling in there now
and [ __ ] you can go online and find
a better selection of clothes the exact
[ __ ]
garment that you want delivered to your
door
for a fraction of that price fraction of
the cost
so that's the end of the mississippi
used to be the towns where all these
little crossroads where they had a
little gas station
and maybe they had a little corner store
and then they had like a little general
type store where you could buy some
tough skins
all that shit's gone now you know
[ __ ]
uh internet [ __ ] killed all that [ __ ]
amazon
doesn't matter where you are now you
could be out in [ __ ]
[ __ ] ellisville mississippi with
[ __ ] population 500.
and you can get the baddest ass [ __ ]
jacket
like something that you bought in
downtown new york you could buy it
you're just right there in the middle of
ellisville with that [ __ ] it's just not
the same world as it was
you can be anywhere at any time and get
anything from anywhere at any time
it's just mind-blowing to me you know
the more i think about it it happens
slowly
i told a story when it first started but
now it's a fully developed [ __ ]
force of nature in this society
if you're young you don't understand how
that impacted things
and how much a difference that made in
people's lives
i mean now you could be from a little
tiny nothing town and still look pretty
cool
because you're wearing the same clothes
that somebody in some club down in new
york could get
back in the day a person living in that
town like i said was wearing some
[ __ ] tough skins
and some [ __ ] cheap ass [ __ ]
sneakers just whatever they had locally
and of course you know there's no
selection locally back in those little
towns
so you look like a [ __ ] po dump yeah
you just did you had no choice it was
like a
soviet [ __ ] economy you could only
buy what was in the damn local store and
there was no selection
back in the day i used to have to order
banned t-shirts from
a company called burning airlines in new
jersey yeah
that was the only place that i could get
cool ass t-shirts like all my bauhaus
shirts all that kind of alien sexy and
all that kind of [ __ ] i got those back
in the [ __ ] 80s
and if you from there and if you didn't
live in a cool
area and you were buying local clothes
you look like a [ __ ] dork
well yeah you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a conspiracy it's a [ __ ]
conspiracy they wanted all the people in
the small towns to look like
[Laughter]
supply and demand well there was no
[ __ ] choice
to anything yeah you know man you went
to the [ __ ]
jcpenney's there's not much choice at jc
penney's
yeah you your age group and [ __ ]
being a guy you can
you can have something off of this rack
and this rack and this rack the rest of
this [ __ ] for old ladies
and [ __ ] old people i kind of feel
like jason penny was pretty much
yeah that's true i mean but you know
maybe not
i'm thinking of terms and [ __ ] trying
to take you back to 81
yeah to 83 i remember in those little
[ __ ] towns the way that [ __ ] was
i don't remember yeah it was hell even
it was a relatively larger town
where i grew up yeah it was really
really hard
to find anything although i will note
that we did have judy's jazzy boutique
which which those two was a mother and
daughter
and they had all the stripper clothes
they had a whole room of sex toys
they had all like all the rock stars
from central florida would
come to daytona and shop there it was in
like the worst area town where all the
hookers and drug addicts hung out
but it was a cool ass place and [ __ ] man
if you were gonna go there you better
spend all day because they would talk to
you
like judah judy and uh her mom normal
would talk to you all [ __ ] day long
and they would tell you about uh jen
from the jenna torturers and the last
time she'd been in there because they
were friends of hers and it's just like
they would tell you all the people that
had to come in there it was like
it was really fun i miss those days i'm
sure that they're probably dead by now
because they were old back then
but that was kind of the only cool we
had a couple cool places in daytona we
had judy's jazzy boutique
we had mandala which was a
used bookstore run by old hippies which
was really awesome
i used to go there all the time and for
a little while we had
a place called criminal records this is
way back in the late 80s early 90s which
was
a used record store and it was run by a
dude that
actually went to my high school and he
had just graduated or graduated a year
or two before me
and he opened up a record store and that
was where i went to get like all
because it was tiny but they had like
really really cool [ __ ] we had atlantic
sounds too
that was like a much bigger like indie
record store
that might be still there i'm not sure
yeah it's asking if he's being blocked
i think there's automatic censorship on
the facebook comments
if you [ __ ] crashed either if you
curse it [ __ ] probably goes away
or probably [ __ ] deletes your comment
i don't
know it looks now i see um is it still
going on your end it looks yeah it's
still going okay it's not going you guys
can still hear us right
i mean my chat stopped a long time ago
maybe we can uh
go ahead and um shut the show down then
maybe
we have more problems yeah i mean
oh [ __ ] well does it go they can hear us
okay guys they can hear us but it
[ __ ] looks like we're starting to
have some serious problems here yeah my
[ __ ] froze up
and it might be time to go ahead and
shut the show down we'll see you guys in
it uh
what are we next saturday we're going to
be streaming saturdays we'll see you
guys then
yeah sorry we got to cut it short but
we're having technical problems we're
having some technical problems
i guess you guys can still see us yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah just
gonna shut it up all right so we've been
going for a couple hours